SPEAKER 1: Join us
now as we proudly
celebrate the 100th episode
of the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hello, and
welcome to episode number
100 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am so excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why, I wonder?
MARK MANDEL: (HIGH-PITCHED
VOICE) We have Vint Cert
on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So excited
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We just
finished an amazing, amazing
interview with Vint Cerf, one
of the fathers of the internet.
And I feel like there's
no intro necessary.
There's no cool
things of the week.
But the cool thing of the week
is we interviewed Vint Cerf.
MARK MANDEL: Vint Cerf.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
feel like we should just
give all of our audience
this present, and just enjoy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's a long
interview, so we want
to make sure you have enough
time to listen to it all.
So yeah, let's just
jump straight into it.
It's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
This is all for you.
Enjoy.
So it is with an
incredible honor
that we are welcoming
today Vint Cerf,
one of the fathers
of the internet,
as the Wikipedia says to the
Google Cloud Platform Podcast
to celebrate episode 100.
Vint, thank you so much
for joining us today.
VINT CERF: I am just delighted.
This is the kind
of conversation I
live for so I am looking
forward to the questions
and the repartee.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I'm incredibly
excited because I've been
a huge fan for a very
long time, obviously.
But also because I took a
selfie with you three years ago
in a cafe in Mountain View.
And since then,
I've always wanted
to have a longer conversation.
So all of this podcast
was just as an excuse
to get to meet you again,
so thank you for joining us.
[LAUGHTER]
VINT CERF: Well, as I say,
I really am delighted.
And there is so much
to say about how
Google has transformed its world
in the Google Cloud Platform.
It's something
that we can all be
proud of but also recognize
huge amount of work
lying ahead to make it more
useful for our own internal
purposes and for the users that
we have all around the world.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, before we get stuck
into all that stuff-- because,
oh my God, I'm so excited.
If anyone hasn't had the
pleasure of knowing, reading,
or hearing about Vint Cerf--
Vint, do you want to give
us a little bit about you
and your background, and
what you do at Google?
VINT CERF: Well, sure,
I'd be happy to do that.
I've been at Google since 2005.
I joined as Vice President
and Chief Internet Evangelist.
And I confess to you that I
did not ask for that title.
I was asked what title did
I want, and I said Archduke.
[LAUGHTER]
And Larry, and Eric, and Sergey
ran off, and they came back
and they said, you know,
the previous Archduke
was Ferdinand, and he
was assassinated in 1914,
and it started World
War I. Maybe that's
not a good title to have.
Why don't you be our
Chief Internet Evangelist.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, OK, I can
do that, considering
that I'd been doing
it for about 35 years
before I joined Google.
So of course, before
that I had many roles
to play in the evolution
of the internet.
And I'd like to think I
still have a role to play.
Eric Schmidt, our
executive chairman,
pointed out to me that I
wasn't allowed to retire.
I said, why not?
And he said, because you're
only half-done, there's still
3 and 1/2 billion
people to convert,
to get up on the internet.
And he's right about that.
There's still much
work to be done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so that
actually ties up really well
with one of our first
questions, which is so what
does Vint Cerf do day to day?
VINT CERF: Well, fortunately
my life is not repetitive.
Every day is new and different.
I have many meetings.
Like today, for example, I
was at the Inter-American
Development Bank for
the morning meeting
with people who are interested
in making major investments
in infrastructure.
They're trying to
understand how they
can take actions that
will improve access
to the internet in
the developing world.
And they're trying to
understand what conditions
need to be in place so that
any investment they might make
will have productive results.
And in that case,
of course we're
worried about the
entire ecosystem
surrounding the implementation
and operation of the internet
and the creation
of new applications
that will be useful to people
locally in local languages,
in addition to
facilitating visibility
for companies in the rest of
the world, which is something
we try to do for people who
are advertising their products
and services.
So I spend a lot of time,
both here in Washington
and on the road, on
policy-related matters that
have to do with the use
and abuse of the internet.
That's another big
theme, which is
that once you put the general
public up on the internet,
you get what you
sort of deserve,
which is the general
public, including
people that don't have your
best interests in mind.
And so a big issue
for us and others
that offer services
on the net is
how to deal with people
who inject bad information
onto the net or who
commit fraud, who bully
people, who distribute malware.
There are a variety
of things that we
are well aware of
thanks to headlines
that are harmful in the
network environment.
And so our job is
to do everything
we can at Google to limit
the kinds of damage that
can be done while at the same
time enhancing and enabling
all kinds of very positive
applications on the network.
So our search engine
is very much a tool
that people use
to find out what's
available on the network,
what products and services are
there, not just on the net,
but in the general nearby areas
or even around the world?
So part of my job
is to help people
think their way through what
conditions they need to create,
if they don't already exist,
to both build and operate
pieces of the internet and then
construct applications on top--
how to enable it to be
beneficial to the people who
are trying to use this
far-flung global system.
I'm in the research
group it turns out,
and report up to
John Giannandrea,
so I also get exposed to
a lot of the things that
are going on on
the research side,
especially in artificial
intelligence, machine
learning, quantum
computing, and things
like that, which are well
beyond my personal capability,
but I'm fascinated by.
On top of which, Google has
been very generous with my time,
and so I do outside activities
that contribute also to this.
So I sit on the National Science
Board overseeing the National
Science Foundation, which is
doing a great deal of research
in all the various sciences,
including computer science.
I had been chairman of the
Americas Registry for Internet
Numbers, until the beginning
of this year, which
oversees the allocation
of internet address space
to people in the Caribbean
and North America.
I was chairman of the
Internet Corporation
for Assigned Names and
Numbers from 2000 to 2007,
again a major component of
the internet infrastructure
managing the domain name
system and top-level IP address
allocation.
Google has been very
willing to allow
me to spend time in the internet
space in one way or another,
whether it's directly
associated with Google or more
generally with the
internet infrastructure.
And so I'm very
grateful for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: That's so
much stuff to unpack there.
I think you clearly do
so much amazing things.
Why don't we sort
of go back a little.
I'm very curious about the
history of some of this stuff.
It's actually kind of hilarious.
We were talking
about this earlier.
Francesc is in Paris, France.
I'm currently in
Melbourne, Australia.
You're in Washington.
The very network
and infrastructure
that you fathered, for
lack of a better term,
makes this whole thing possible.
But you are known as one of
the fathers of the internet.
So thank you very much for that,
making our jobs all possible.
VINT CERF: Well, to the extent
that this has been beneficial,
I think for the credit.
To the extent that some
damage has been done,
I refuse to accept
the responsibility.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for the good parts.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems fair enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
VINT CERF: Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
for all the good parts.
But I'm super curious.
I mean, when you were working in
this, back at the origin state.
Many people consider
the internet sort of--
for those of us who
have become used to it
and who have access to it
become almost a human right
or a requisite
part of existence.
Did you ever see that in the
pathway of this distributed
network you were building?
VINT CERF: Well, I certainly
never anticipated the notion
that access to internet might
be considered a human right.
And as you may know, I have
published at least one op-ed
that suggested that that
was not a good formulation.
I'd like to come back to that.
But let's go back to the
origins of this system.
It was originally funded by the
American Defense Department.
My partner in the design is
Robert Kahn, who at the time
was at the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency.
This is way back in
late '72 or early
'73 of the previous century.
God, that sounds
like a long time ago.
And it was, actually.
So Bob had this idea that open
networking would be a good
thing, that the packet switching
technology of the ARPANET
project could be replicated
in multiple networks--
some that are mobile
radio, some over satellite,
some over a dedicated wireline--
and that these
multiplicity packets,
which networks needed to
be interconnected in a way
that created commonality.
And the only way we
could do that was
to develop a set
of protocols that
would let these disparate
packets, which nets
look like one gigantic network,
although made up of many nets.
So the internet is a
network of networks.
We developed the protocols and
the concepts to do that in 1973
and published a paper in 1974,
developed the detailed specs
for the protocols in late '74,
started implementation in 1975,
ran through a series of
iterations, four of them or so,
stabilized that design in
1978, started implementing it
on many different
operating systems,
turned the system on
on January 1, 1983.
Now, you might say did you
have any idea that it was
going to be global in scope?
The answer is absolutely,
because we imagined
this would be needed by the
American Defense Department
for command and control.
That means it has to work
no matter where the Defense
Department deployed, which
meant it had to work everywhere
in the world.
So we were already thinking
in global terms at the time
that this design was being done.
We actually didn't
quite get it right.
We thought that a 32-bit
internet numerical address
space would be enough at
least to do an experiment.
So we designed the system to
have 4.3 billion terminations.
And that, I think,
might have been
more than there were people
in the world at the time we
were doing this work.
However, we ran out around 2011.
Fortunately the engineers
who do the standards
for the internet in the
Internet Engineering Task Force
could foresee that we
were going to run out
and designed a new format
for the internet packets that
had a 128-bit addressing space.
Now, we're not talking
about domain names
which are alphanumeric--
for example, Google.com.
We're talking about an
underlying numerical address
space sort of like
phone numbers,
although the analogy
sometimes doesn't work.
But it's similar in nature.
So 128-bit address
space is also referred
to as IP version 6,
internet protocol version
6, Which gives you 3.4 times
10 to the 38 addresses, which
is a big number.
Google has been at the
forefront of implementing IPv6
for the various applications
that it supports,
and it will continue to
support both v4 and v6 address
spaces until such time as v4
seems to be no longer needed.
So we are among the
good guys who have been
pushing v6 implementations.
It's probably got to about
30% worldwide on average,
although there are
some networks that
are 100% capable of doing
both the older version
32-bit addresses
and the 128-bit.
And there are some networks
that haven't done anything
yet at all.
So there's still
work to be done.
The internet of things, which
is threatening to overwhelm us
in terms of numbers
of devices on the net,
could have as many as 50
billion devices in the system
by the early 2020s,
which we'll definitely
need the IPv6 expanded
address space.
Mobile phones also
are dependent on this.
The thing called LTE or
long term evolution, which
is sometimes called
4G, also makes
use of IPv6 address space.
So you can see this
proliferation of devices
is driving that.
Finally, with regard to
internet of things, something
our company cares
a great deal about,
there are both the
production of these devices,
at Nest, for example,
and at Google,
and there is the cloud
component of this,
which is helping to
monitor the devices,
to provide artificial
intelligence
applications through those
devices, such as Google
Assistant by way of Google
Home, or by way of the Pixel,
or the Chromebooks, or
other kinds of equipment
that Google makes.
So we are now faced with
a proliferation of devices
and also a great deal
of concern for safety,
and security, privacy,
and reliability,
of this increasingly
large system of devices
all interacting with each other.
And so that's certainly
going to be a challenge,
not only for Google but for
all the other parties who
are beginning to participate
in the internet of things.
Now, there's lots
more to be said there,
but let me stop
there and just say
that there's lots that I've
been finding myself engaged in
because of this huge investment
that we and others are making
in internet-enabled devices.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So to go back
a little bit to the more society
side of the internet,
I'm curious about
were you expecting this
huge change in society?
Literally, the internet has
changed the way we do things.
We communicate, we
work, we do everything.
Was that something
you expected too?
VINT CERF: Yes.
And I can prove this in the
following sense-- in 1992,
I became the founding
president of something
called the Internet Society.
And why did we call it that?
Because I believe that a
society would emerge out
of the internet.
And indeed it has.
That society may not be
one that we like 100%.
And this is what
happens when you
create new infrastructure--
people find ways to use it
and to abuse it.
This is like cars and the
roads that they drive on.
People get drunk, and
they drive the cars
and run into each other
and run into things,
and kill themselves
or harm other people.
The internet has its downsides.
It has lowered the barrier
to access to information.
It has lowered the barrier for
expression to practically zero.
And I've always thought that was
a good thing, that we want more
ability for people to
both express themselves,
and to share what they
know, and to find out
what other people
are willing to share.
But at the same
time, we also have
to recognize that there are
people who get on the net
and do not have the rest of
the society's best interests
at heart.
So we worry about
fraud, we worry
about false information,
or misinformation,
or so-called fake news
and things like that.
We worry about malware that
people create and propagate
through the network
and cause harm
to devices that are
attached to the network
or essentially grab
control over those devices
and turn them into what
are called botnets, which
are sort of robotic
networks, that can then
be used to generate
denial of service attacks
or to generate spam, or to
do other kinds of things that
are potentially harmful.
So this huge global system,
which has literally,
I would say,
millions of networks,
including the local one that
you run at home, for instance,
and then the big gigantic
globe-spanning networks
of the telcos and the cablecos.
This system is, like every
other infrastructure,
capable of being abused.
And we're experiencing
the effects
of this society
which is emerging out
of this technology.
So now we have to
struggle with protecting
people against harmful
experiences online.
And sometimes we can
build technical means
of protecting them-- detecting
malware, for example,
defending against denial
of service attacks,
filtering out spam, which we do
very well in our Gmail service.
So we have these technical
means of protecting people--
two-factor authentication
to keep accounts
from being seized or hijacked.
But you can't sure that you
can prevent all harmful acts
from occurring on the net
through technical means.
And so you also have to build
in mechanisms for saying,
if we detect or catch you
doing some of these bad things,
there will be consequences.
And here now we get into
international agreements,
because the network
is global in scope.
And a perpetrator of harm
may be in one jurisdiction,
and their victim
in another across
international boundaries,
which immediately
says that we need to have
cooperative interactions
among the countries
that are part
of the internet environment.
There are just so many issues
here that we have to cope with,
not only as Google but also
more broadly as citizens
in the online environment.
So I'm actually spending
a lot of my time
asking questions about policy,
for example, and how it can
be implemented and enforced.
Where does the policy come from?
Can we use multistakeholder
processes to establish policy?
And then use law enforcement
and trade agreements
and other kinds of
things to enforce safety
for the people who are online
to enforce their privacy,
to protect them against
various forms of abuse.
And I might point
out one more thing,
as long as I'm
rattling on here--
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Go ahead.
VINT CERF: That this lowering
of barrier for speech means that
you and I and
others on the net--
the 3 and 1/2 billion or so
that we believe are online--
now have an additional
challenge before them.
And that is to think
critically about what
we're seeing and hearing
in this environment,
because it's easy to
inject malware or easy--
I should say, inject
false information
or mistaken information
in the system.
And our search engine finds both
the good stuff and sometimes
the not-so-good stuff.
And so as users
of the network, we
suddenly inherit
this responsibility
for thinking critically
about what we're actually
seeing and hearing
and questioning,
where did it come from?
What's the basis for my
belief that this is useful
versus bad information?
I think a lot of people
are a little uncomfortable
that they suddenly inherited
this responsibility.
But indeed, if you want to use
the network to best effect,
you actually have to think
critically about that.
MARK MANDEL: So I
think this segues
into an interesting topic,
as well, when we're talking
about the safety of the
internet and malware
and also, from a
societal point of view,
how do you think this affects
either net neutrality,
or the idea of net neutrality?
Does it have any
impact on how we
should be thinking about that?
VINT CERF: So this is
a very good question.
The term net neutrality, as
I'm sure your listeners know,
is used in different ways in
different parts of the world.
So we have to be careful
about the use of the term
and ask, OK, in what context
are we asking the question?
In the United
States, for instance,
during the early 1990s, there
were about 8,000 internet
service providers.
This was a dial up system.
And to reach a particular
internet server or service,
you just dialed a
particular number
that got you to a modem bank.
If you didn't like the
service, it was easy to switch.
You just dialed a
different number.
And so there was quite a bit of
user choice in terms of access
to the internet.
Along comes broadband,
and suddenly there
are very few providers
of broadband service--
the telcos, the cablecos,
and that's about it.
So although in
recent times, we're
starting to see wireless
services increasing
in their data rate, so that
they could be considered
broadband as well.
So during this period--
roughly in the very late
1990s, early 2000s--
in the US, if you were
looking at broadband service
as a consumer, you didn't
have very much choice.
If you were in the rural
parts of the country,
you had zero choice
for broadband.
No one was providing
that service.
If you were in the
suburban areas,
you might have a choice of
either a telco or a cableco.
And in the urban areas,
you might have a choice
of two suppliers of broadband.
So not everyone was uniformly
able to get competitive access
to broadband service.
This is still a problem today.
And the absence of
enough competition
and choice for the consumers--
there's always the risk that a
monopoly supplier will in fact
interfere with people's freedom
to use the network any way
they want.
For example, if you in
the vertical business
of providing video services in
addition to underlying internet
service, it might be
tempting to interfere
with a competitor's
video service going
through the internet channel.
And in fact, there
were some indications
of this kind of bad
behavior on the part of some
of the broadband carriers who
would inhibit voiceover IP
or would interfere
with streaming video
in order to induce customers
to use their service,
or possibly to interfere with
intermediate carriers who
were trying to carry traffic
and who were getting squeezed.
And therefore quality
of service suffered.
So we have what I think are
fewer choices as consumers.
And as the choice goes down,
then the risk factors go up.
And so now you need
some regulation
in order to assure that
the consumer interests are
protected.
So the net neutrality
rules mostly, as I see it,
in the US are intended
to limit the ability
of a broadband internet
service access provider
to interfere with what
you do with the network,
where you go on the net,
what products and services
you exercise.
That's why it's been a
big issue here in the US.
The ability of the Federal
Communications Commission
to step in and defend the users'
choices was limited for a time
because there was a
choice made by the FCC
to treat the internet as
an unregulated information
service.
And subsequently
there was an attempt
to put in principles for
net neutrality or defense
against the practices that
were anti-competitive.
When the FCC tried to
enforce those principles,
it was told by the
Supreme Court that you
didn't have a legal basis
for exercising that control,
because the FCC had decided
that the internet was
an unregulated service.
So they had no basis
for regulation.
This caused the FCC,
under Tom Wheeler,
to shift the internet
service into Title II, which
is the telecom title,
re-instantiating the FCC's
ability to regulate.
And now, of course, under
the new administration,
Ajit Pai, the
current chairman, is
trying to undo that
particular decision
and to put the internet back
into an unregulated state,
which means that there would be
no legal basis for protecting
users whose freedom of
choice may have been harmed
by a non-neutral provider.
So at this stage
in the US, there's
some uncertainty about
protecting user interests.
In other parts of the world,
there may be enough competition
so the users can simply
choose a different carrier
or different internet
service provider
in order to get service in there
and thereby use competition
as a balancing effect.
Here in the US, there
isn't enough competition,
and so regulation seems to
be the only alternative.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is really concerning.
I was actually unaware
of the last part,
so thank you for sharing that.
Since you're already
mentioning access
to the internet on other
parts of the world,
I'm curious about,
since you were
able to predict a little
bit that the internet would
be a global thing, and
it changed the world,
do you think that having
the rest of the world
get access to the internet
will change it again?
Or it will be more of
a progressive thing?
VINT CERF: Well, it will
certainly change it.
For one thing, half
the people in the world
don't have access yet.
And we already know
some of the things that
have happened, positive and
negative, for the people who
are already online.
The reason that I
think it will change,
although maybe not
in predictable ways,
is that the people who
will get access next,
the next billion
or two, probably
will get access through a
wireless method rather than
a wired method.
They probably will have
smart mobile phones
which now are heavily
populated all around the world.
They will have needs which
have evolved over time.
And so those of us who have
been online, especially
in the broadband world, let's
say, for the last 15 years
or so have experienced
the internet largely
through laptops.
And now, of course,
the rest of the world
is going to experience the
internet through smartphones
and possibly other smart devices
as the internet of things
continues to deploy.
So their experiences and
their needs for service
may turn out to be quite
different from what we
experienced 10 or 15 years ago.
The consequence of that is
that there is opportunity
everywhere.
And on top of which,
solutions to issues
arising in this vastly
increased demand
may actually come
from the people
who are new to the
internet as opposed
to people who've been
around for a while.
Don't forget that
intelligence is uniformly
distributed around the world.
But a lot of the
smart people may not
be able to exercise their
intelligence to good effect
with regard to internet, because
the opportunities may not
be there.
There may not be incentive
for investment, for example.
They may not have the moral
equivalent of venture capital
and risk taking, which is
endemic in the Silicon Valley,
less so in other
parts of the world.
So I think that
the newer inductees
into the internet family
will experience new needs
and come up with new
requirements, but also
new solutions, which
may and propagate back
into the rest of the internet.
So to give you an example,
in China I've been told,
in the eastern
part of China, that
don't bother carrying cash.
Everything is paid
for with the mobile.
And even the beggars hold
up their little mobiles
and say, take a picture
of this little quad symbol
and transfer money
to me, which that has
to be a very weird feeling--
somebody who's begging using
a smartphone, and saying,
hey, wait a minute.
You have a smartphone,
and you're begging?
How does that work?
But I will say, in
India, for example,
where digital identities
have been issued
to some 800 million people.
These people suddenly become
visible to the government,
whereas before they were not.
And they become
eligible for benefits
that they couldn't get before.
Estonia only has a
million and a half people.
They are as heavily networked
and internet-enabled
as any country in the world.
And they are an
interesting place to look,
because when 100 percent of
the population is online with
digital identities
and everything else,
there are things you can do
relying on the fact that 100%
of the people have access,
as opposed to a country like
the US where maybe
80% have access,
and the other 20% don't.
So you have to accommodate
that statistic.
So here we are with examples
of places that are deeply
embedded in the internet system
and in digital applications.
It's like explorers going out
into a territory which nobody
has been in and
reporting back to us
what's out there so
we don't have to make
the same mistakes they do.
MARK MANDEL: Speaking
of explorers,
thinking possibly
way in the future
or possibly not depending
on some of the advents
that we've been seeing
lately around interplanetary
and space travel, when you
built the internet as it was,
were you thinking about possibly
interplanetary networks,
having space stations that
currently orbit the earth
and having them communicate
backwards and forwards?
Was that something that
you built into the protocol
and design of the system?
Or do you think it's going
to change going forward?
VINT CERF: Actually, I
know it's going to change
because we're already there.
We're operating an
interplanetary system.
And the TCP/IP
protocol did not work.
And we-- when I say we, I'm
speaking of the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory at NASA plus now many
of the other NASA laboratories.
I started work on an
interplanetary extension
of the internet in 1998 at JPL.
And we very quickly realized
that the TCP protocols
were designed in a low-latency
context with relatively
high reliability.
In space, you have
the inverse of that.
You have low reliability, and
you have variable and often
very long latency as we're
talking about hours to days.
So your ping is not your
friend here in terms of network
management and interaction.
You don't really
know how long it's
going to take for an
interplanetary packet
to get to its destination.
It may have to hop through
multiple sites, from Earth
to Mars to Jupiter and wherever.
So we had to develop a whole
new suite of protocols, which
we called the Bundle
Protocol, which
is an instance of what is called
delay and disruption-tolerant
networking.
So in fact we have thought
our way through that.
We've now deployed first a
prototype system on Mars,
and now we've deployed the most
recent and fully standardized
protocols on the
International Space Station.
And we hope those same
standardized protocols
will be on board
spacecraft which
will be going to Mars and
elsewhere during the 2020s.
So in that particular
case, we had
to accept that the original
design simply was not
capable of accommodating the
kinds of lossy, long, highly
variable delay that the space
environment presents us with.
And so that's why we
designed a new system.
But it is interoperable with
the rest of the internet.
It's just that the
rest of the internet
isn't organized around
that suite of protocols.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So that is amazing.
Sincerely, I'm really
impressed with that.
I'm wondering now
is there something
else other than TCP/IP,
which clearly there is.
Are these protocols still based
on the end-to-end principle?
Could you tell us
a little bit, what
is the end-to-end principle?
And is that something
that you're forgetting now
to go interplanetary?
Or is it actually
even more important?
VINT CERF: Well,
end-to-end basically
said you put something
into the network,
and in theory, it should pop
out looking exactly the same
on the other end.
And you rely on the fact
the packets aren't being
altered or modified in between.
This is still very much a
principle that lots of us
would like to hang onto as part
of the internet characteristic.
The reason that's so
valuable is that if you're
building protocols that are
at the edges of the network,
building up from the
basic internet protocol,
this end-to-end
principle helps a lot,
because you can
assume that what was
put in by some party in some
distant part of the network
arrives intact at the other end.
Now there are ways
of assuring that
by using cryptography,
for example,
or digital signatures
and other things
to assure integrity of
the end-to-end concepts.
There have been
some, let me say,
breaks in this
end-to-end notion.
For example, as the internet
deployed commercially
in the late '80s
and early '90s, we
saw corporations
building firewalls
around their corporate
assets in order
to try to protect
against attacks coming
through the network to
their targeted corporate
infrastructure.
And that actually
introduced, down
in the guts of the network,
something which potentially
interfered with the
end-to-end principle,
because in fact the packets
were getting examined,
they might be destroyed, they
might be perhaps not altered,
necessarily.
Although there is
the possibility
of doing what's called network
address translation, which
in fact does interfere with
the end-to-end principle,
because what may
be sent on one end
is not how it looks when it's
received on the other end.
So I've never been a big fan
of this whole network address
translation because it violates
the end-to-end principle.
I think that over time
we will ultimately
discover that firewall motions
are inadequate to protect
against hazards on the network.
And then ultimately every
device on the network
has to be able to defend itself.
When the original
design was done,
we assumed that anyone
could talk to anyone else
because we didn't know who would
usefully be able to do that.
But we also said you don't
have to talk to anybody if you
don't want to.
And so if you receive a packet
from some random source,
and you can't identify
them, or you haven't gotten
the handshake that says,
yes, I know who you are,
and yes, we have cryptographic
shared variables, if you're not
satisfied, you can throw
the packet away or send back
a rejection notice.
I expect devices to do that.
I think that a
responsible design
is to inhibit the device from
doing anything which it doesn't
think it is safe, which means
don't talk to people that you
can't identify.
So I think that
we are moving back
towards the end-to-end principle
and with the philosophy
that you don't have to
communicate with some device
that you don't recognize.
And in fact, you
should enforce that.
And I think that will actually
improve some of the safety
and security on the network.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
I am just keeping a very
close eye on the time.
So we've been talking
about very serious stuff,
and I want to make sure we
throw in some more fun things
in here, as well.
Noticing about how the planning
that you put into place when
you first built this whole
network and the planning
that you've had subsequently
since about looking
to the future, I'm curious
to know, though, what's
been the most surprising
or possibly the most
whimsical thing that you've
seen happen on the internet,
that you were like,
that was never--
I never thought that
was going to happen?
VINT CERF: Well, let's see.
Certainly to be
fair about this, I
think the arrival of the World
Wide Web was quite a surprise.
I had seen something
similar to that Douglas
Engelbart developed and
demonstrated as early as 1968.
In fact, if your
listeners would like
to go online and Google
the mother of all demos,
you will see something
quite astonishing,
which is the demonstration
of a kind of World Wide
Web in a box, in one machine
at SRI International in Menlo
Park, California.
Much of the World
Wide Web is picked up
in that particular
demonstration.
He had hyperlinking.
For example, of documents
produced in the online system.
He built a mouse
so that you could
point to things on the
screen and click on them,
to say pay attention to
that, or go to that document,
or perform and edit this
document at the place where
I'm pointing.
So he had to invent the mouse.
He invented portrait
mode displays,
which made things look
more like a sheet of paper
than the sort of yellow,
and green displays
that were common in the day.
So Tim Berners-Lee
of course comes along
in late 1991 at
CERN in Switzerland
with an expansive network-based
idea for a similar thing.
I'm not sure whether he even
knew about the online system
from Englebart at the time.
And of course, this evolves
into Netscape Communications
product, with the follow
on to the Mosaic browser.
And it suddenly
triggered this avalanche
of content being
created by people
who were able to either
write their own HTML
or had an application
that did that for them.
I was totally blown away
by the amount of content
that suddenly
showed up on the net
that people just
wanted to share.
They weren't asking for any
kind of compensation at all.
They just thought,
well, maybe people
would find what I know
interesting to them.
And so I'm seeing this
pile of stuff just flowing
into the net in the
mid-1990s thinking--
and then of course,
Google comes along
with its search engine
following Altavista, and Archie,
and several other
things, Yahoo, and so on,
which helped to try to
make sense out of this
is increasing pile of content.
I was amazed that people would
share so much information
without expectation
of compensation.
And I'm pretty sure
they were doing it
for the satisfaction of
knowing that what they knew
might be useful
to somebody else.
I think there is this
secret desire in all of us
to believe that
we've done something
that's useful for someone else.
We've shared something that's
helpful to someone else.
And the internet
is a perfect medium
in which to try to do that.
So that certainly surprised me.
Now, as far as
funny things-- well,
of course, when the first
internet picture frame showed
up I remember thinking, what?
What do you mean the
internet-enabled picture frame?
[LAUGHTER]
What does that mean?
And of course, people said,
well it downloads images
from a website and then
cycles through them.
And that means that
grandparents can see what
their grandchildren are doing.
When they get up in
the morning, they just
look at the picture frame,
and it's just updated itself
from the latest website.
And that surprised me.
On the other hand,
I do remember,
I think it was probably in the
early 1990s or maybe late '80s,
there was a convention
or an exposition
called Interop, which
stood for interoperability,
that was started by a
friend of mine, Dan Lynch.
And during one of
the Interop shows,
somebody decided to put a
toaster up on the network
so you could send an SNMP
control packet, say, how
burned you wanted your toast.
And we were all saying,
oh, isn't that funny.
Ha ha ha.
And then someday everybody will
have internet-enabled devices
on them.
Well, now here we are.
The internet of things
is rapidly flowing on us
But I remember at the time
we were all thinking that
would be pretty funny.
I used to make jokes
about, oh, yes, some day
every light bulb will
have its own IP address.
Well, guess what.
Philips makes an
internet-controled light bulb,
as do others, I suppose.
And they all have
their IP addresses.
So you know, don't make fun
of things, because who knows.
They may come true.
So those are some of the things.
And I suppose the
obligatory observation--
they never expected as many cat
videos to show up on the net
as have.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow.
Who spends their
time watching cats?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so you
mentioned Tim Berners-Lee
and the World Wide Web.
And as part of the
research for this episode,
I'm kind of forced at
asking this question.
I've seen a picture of the two
of you wearing both T-shirts.
Where you're wearing
a T-shirt that says,
I did not invent the web.
And he's wearing
a T-shirt saying,
I did not invent the
internet, which is by itself
an amazing T-shirt, but I
think the important part here
is that it is the
only picture I've ever
seen of you not wearing a suit.
VINT CERF: Right.
Well, and I kind of
put that over my coat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Of course.
VINT CERF: So there's a story
about the three piece suits
if you want to finish this
interview with that story.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
VINT CERF: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
VINT CERF: So this is
a very simple story.
I'm at Stanford University.
I've been running the internet
research program from there
as an assistant professor.
And the Advanced
Research Projects Agency
says, why don't you
come to Washington
and just run the whole thing,
and run the packet satellite
program, and the
packet radio program,
and the packet security
program along with internet.
So I agree.
And my wife, who's from Kansas
but was with me at Stanford
says you're going to Washington?
Or we're going to Washington?
Three-piece suits.
So she goes out and she
buys three three-piece suits
from Saks Fifth Avenue at
Stanford Shopping Center,
including a seersucker
three-piece suit
because she knows
that it's going
to be hot and humid during
the summertime in Washington.
So I show up around
August or so at ARPA.
And the next thing
I know, I am asked
to go testify at some
committee at the Congress.
And I'm wearing my
three-piece seersucker suit.
So I show up, and
I do my testimony.
And I go back to
ARPA, and weeks go by.
And one day, the director of
ARPA calls me into his office
and says, I want to
talk to you about
your Congressional testimony.
And I'm thinking,
did I screw up?
Am I about to lose
my government job?
Is it the end of the world?
And so I sit down,
and he says, oh, I
have a letter from the
chairman of the committee
in front of me.
He says thank you very much
for Dr. Cerf's testimony.
By the way, he's the
best-dressed guy from ARPA
we've ever seen.
[LAUGHTER]
And I took that as
positive feedback.
So I've been wearing
three-piece suits ever since.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is amazing.
That has not changed yet.
I think you are still probably
the best-dressed person in tech
that I know.
VINT CERF: Well, I ought to
tilt my camera here so that you
can see that I am indeed
wearing a three-piece suit here
in my Washington office.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm so happy
I am recording this right now.
MARK MANDEL: For those who
are listening on the podcast,
Vint is wearing a
three-piece suit right now.
VINT CERF: Well,
actually it was very
appropriate to wear a
three-piece suit in any case,
as I was at the Inter-American
Development Bank
with a whole lot of
very senior people.
And so I think it's a sign of
respect to show up well-dressed
when you were speaking to people
who are more important than you
are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm so
sad right now that I'm
weren't just a T-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Vint, unfortunately we
are running out of time.
I would love to spend more
time chatting with you,
but I really appreciate
you taking the time out
of your day to chat with
us, and come with us
and celebrate our 100th episode.
It's been absolutely lovely
and a complete delight
speaking to you today.
VINT CERF: Well, thank
you so much for that.
I am looking forward to spending
more time with the Google Cloud
team.
And as you know, we are making
some very serious investments
not only in increased
scale, but also
the diversity in the system.
So as time goes on,
we are going to see
not only our conventional CPUs
but the graphics processing
units the GPUs, and now
increasingly the TensorFlow
processing units for doing
multilevel neural networks.
And eventually, assuming
we're successful,
we will have quantum
processing units
that will allow
people to do things
faster than they ever could
before for certain kinds
of optimization.
So the system which started
out being a warehouse computing
commodity commonality
is now going
to become a much more diverse
computing platform that
can specialize in to
solve particular problems
that our customers have.
So I'm very excited about this
new heterogeneous computing
environment that Google
brings to its customer base
through the Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
definitely very exciting.
And if you want to come
back to the podcast
and tell us more about it,
we're definitely, definitely
down for that.
VINT CERF: I'd be
delighted to do that.
MARK MANDEL: Anytime.
All right, well
thank you so much.
VINT CERF: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
Goodbye.
VINT CERF: See you
guys on the net.
MARK MANDEL: Oh my God, we
just interviewed Vint Cerf.
This was amazing
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh my God.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Career highlight.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We got to
admit that we've been maybe just
talking about how happy we
were for the last 20 minutes.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
So I want to say, definitely--
this is episode 100.
To all our listeners,
to all the people
who've downloaded our
podcast, to all the people
who have wandered up to us
and said hello, thank you
so much for listening to us.
By you doing that means that
we were able to interview Vint.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Also, thanks to Vint Cerf.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, thanks--
MARK MANDEL: I'm still so giddy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
This was amazing, like a
huge opportunity that I would
have never expected to have.
And it was because long
time ago, October--
MARK MANDEL: 2015.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --2015 we
got together in a meeting,
and you went like, why
don't we do a podcast?
And I was like, OK, whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
a year and a half
later, we interviewed Vint Cerf.
MARK MANDEL: And we
have 100 episodes.
Actually, it's two years.
It's been two years.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Two yea--
oh my God I'm old.
MARK MANDEL: 52 weeks,
weekly episodes.
It's been two years.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
not going to go over
our favorite moments
of the whole podcast
because right now, it was
this episode, clearly.
Without losing any respect for
all of the amazing episodes
we've done before.
Thanks so much also
for all of the guests
that we've had over those
100 amazing episodes.
I feel like there
is one that deserves
an extra mention because
we've had him so often--
Paul Newson.
So Paul Newson, thank you
so much for recording--
I feel like it's been, like,
four episodes at least.
We have a section,
we have a category
of the podcast which
is Paul Newson.
Thanks to him too.
MARK MANDEL: No, absolutely.
And we should also make
mention to a decent chunk
of people who work
behind the scenes who
have also made this possible.
Greg, our manager, Shana, who
runs social, Neil in marketing,
I'm probably going
to miss someone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Don't forget.
MARK MANDEL: Shawn and
Jane, two of our editors.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
Don't forget our editors.
MARK MANDEL: Our
editors are amazing.
They do a wonderful,
wonderful job.
If I've forgotten anyone,
I'm deeply apologetic.
But you're all incredible.
Did I miss anyone?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I don't think so.
And if you did, now
I feel apologetic too
because I don't
know anyone else.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely
you all help so much,
and we are so, so,
so very thankful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I feel like
to celebrate our 100th episode,
since we got this amazing
episode as a present
to our audience, I feel like
our audience should give us
a present back.
MARK MANDEL: They need to
get in contact with us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes,
they should send us
selfies, a 100th episode
selfie or something.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Pictures of puppies, too,
are also very good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, how
can they get in contact
with the podcast?
Go on.
You know you want to do this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
going to do that.
OK.
So you can--
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --send us
your selfies via email at--
MARK MANDEL: hello@gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You can send
us your selfies via Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: At @GCPPodcast.
Podcast
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You can send
us your selfies on Google+.
MARK MANDEL: At +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You can not send
us selfies through our website
because we do not have a form.
But it's--
MARK MANDEL: GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if
I remember correctly,
you can also send
us selfies on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: Hash podcast
on bit.ly/GCP-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, one more.
Reddit, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit.
I forgot about it.
MARK MANDEL: Reddit--
/r/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
So yeah.
Send us your selfies.
We're just curious to know
what are your happy faces
while you were listening
to this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, please do.
Well, Francesc, I
know you're exhausted.
It's a late night
where you are in Paris.
It's a very early morning where
I am in Melbourne, Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am currently retired,
and I have a burger
waiting for me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
but thank you to you
for joining me for 100 episodes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark,
for joining for 100 episodes.
To be honest, it is not
as bad as it sounds.
It was very fun.
MARK MANDEL: It
was-- oh, thanks!
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: On that note--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you all for listening,
and talk to you all next
week for episode 101.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
See you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]